hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
imagine building a living organism from
individual cells once this organism is
built it can move be programmed and do
several assigned tasks all about being
controlled after it runs out of food it
dies and is fully biodegradable now
imagine if this organism was designed by
a computer algorithm well all of this
has just happened this is a fascinating
topic and we'll find out all about it in
this episode you are watching ColdFusion
TV
[Music]
so this breakthrough follows the recent
trend of biological engineering that
we've covered on this channel in
previous cold fusion episodes we've seen
biological robots successfully defeat
cancers of the blood using the body's
own immune system to fight cancer is
called immunotherapy and cartee is the
most promising form of this approach the
reason people are so excited about this
is because it produced incredible
results and patients where all other
treatments fail to work and stem cells
that were injected directly into the
brain to restore movement and make the
wheelchair-bound walk again these stem
cells then triggered the damaged areas
of the brain to repair themselves within
days patients could move limbs again and
begin to speak properly when they
couldn't previously those people who saw
those episodes were completely blown
away but this latest breakthrough is
different this time
the breakthrough by a team of scientists
at the University of Vermont was to
create something completely new it is
the world's first living machine
designed from the ground up Joshua bond
guard a computer scientist and robotics
expert Accola the study sums it all up
what they've created is quote neither a
traditional robot nor unknown species of
animal it's a new class of artifact a
living programmable organism so what's
going on here the researchers repurposed
living cells scraped from frog embryos
and assembled them into entirely new
life forms the original stem cells came
from an African clawed frog known by the
Latin name Xenopus laevis but these
living robots don't resemble any living
creature after being harvested the stem
cells were then separated into single
cells and left to incubate the cells
were cut and joined together under a
microscope the resulting Assembly of
living cells has been dubbed as Zeno
BOTS and they're tiny at just 0.04
inches or one millimeter wide these
robots can move independently and
collectively and survive for weeks at a
time
they could potentially be used to
transport medicines inside a patient's
body as well as other uses and don't
worry who'll get to all of this later on
in the episode but the thing about this
that amazed me the most was how it was
all designed the new creatures were
designed by a supercomputer at the
University of Vermont and then assembled
and tested by biologists at Tufts
University he is how it worked the deep
green supercomputer cluster at the
University of Vermont ran for months at
a time this computer was custom designed
allowing for cutting-edge AI research
four miles east of UVM central campus
now home to the university's new
supercomputer dubbed deep green intended
for research into machine learning and
artificial intelligence the machine said
to be among the 100 most powerful in the
nation it's about 800 to a thousand
normal laptops one of deep greens
graphic processing units removed for
demonstration was impressive enough we
have enemies across the entire cluster
it's almost half a million processing
cores
deep green exceeds petaflop speed one
thousand million million calculations
per second with its wide ranging
applications it is a very big deal this
will allow us to be fairly competitive
with much larger universities and allow
us to do research that we would not have
been able to do it used an evolutionary
algorithm to create thousands of
candidate designs for the new life-forms
the scientists determined a desired task
in this case the task was movement so
the algorithm would create designs
intended to produce the outcome of
movement
within its software the computer would
assemble a few hundred simulated heart
and skin cells into different body forms
the behavior of these cells was governed
by constraints and parameters for
example the maximum muscle power of a
frog heart cell would these parameters
as its guide the algorithm iterated the
life-form designs the more successful
simulated organisms were allowed to
reproduce inside the algorithm while the
failed designs were thrown away after a
hundred independent runs of the
algorithm the most promising designs
were selected for testing and then later
brought to life lead study author Sam
Krugman speaks quote eventually it was
able to give us the science that were
actually transferable to real cells that
was a breakthrough there's no external
control from a remote control or
bioelectricity this is an autonomous
agent it's almost like a wind-up toy as
these biological devices were assembled
into body forms never before seen in
nature the cells began to work together
the heart cells as the muscles
contracted work to provide an ordered
forward motion as simulated and
predicted by the computers design the
contractions of the heart muscles were
the mechanisms for motion the skin cells
on the other hand behaved as a
scaffolding to hold everything together
the organisms managed to survive in
their watery environment for weeks they
were powered by stored energy in the
form of proteins the Zener BOTS moved
objects around in the real world to when
their environment was scattered with
particles the Zener BOTS spontaneously
worked together moving in a circular
motion to push the particles into one
spot so what can these things be used
for Michael Levin co-leader of the study
and director of the center of
regenerative and developmental biology
speaks quote we can imagine many useful
applications of these living robots like
searching out nasty compounds or
radioactive contamination gathering
micro plastics in the oceans traveling
in arteries to scrape out plaque end
quote
the scientists also hint that these
machines could be used to carry medicine
to a specific area inside of a patient
the robots also have the benefit of
healing themselves after being cut quote
we sliced the robot almost in half and
it stitches itself back up and keeps
going and this is something that you
can't do with typical machines end quote
so this is quite significant because
today many technologies are made from
metals concrete or plastic and while
these are great for our needs they can
also create ecological and human health
problems like the growing problem of
plastic pollution in the ocean and the
toxicity of many synthetic materials in
electronics but according to the
scientists quote these xeno bots are
fully biodegradable when they're done
with their job after seven days they're
just dead skin cells end quote so with
all of this in mind people are obviously
going to be split on this issue blurring
the lines between robots and living
organisms our popular subjects and
science fiction many people worry about
the implications of a rapid
technological advancement in ever more
complex biological manipulations Michael
Levin of the study speaks quote when we
start to mess around with complex
systems that we don't understand we're
going to get unintended consequences
nevertheless building on simple organic
forms like the Senna BOTS could also
lead to beneficial discoveries he goes
on if Humanity is going to survive in
the future we need to better understand
how complex properties somehow emerge
from simple rules a first step towards
doing that is to explore how do living
systems decide what an overall behavior
should be and how do we manipulate the
species to get the behaviors we want
it's strange to think that if left
aligned to their natural development the
stem cells taken from the embryonic
frogs would have turned into skin and
heart tissue within living breathing
animals instead in configurations
designed by a computer algorithm they
were constructed by humans and those
cells were assembled into something
completely new a living programmable
robot although the current states of
Zeno BOTS is relatively harmless there
is the potential for future work to
incorporate a nervous system and
countless other applications as this
field of research grows regulations and
ethics guidelines will need to be
seriously considered this is an immense
responsibility for humans to have and
one of the biggest questions to if this
should be done or not is do the benefits
outweigh the risks
at this stage it's impossible to know
though I do think we should be cautious
in how we proceed biological unintended
consequences are no joke but then again
the correct use of such technology to
clean up our oceans or other such
applications could be a game changer for
those who want to read the study the
research has been published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences and the team has made their
source code freely available on github
I'll leave links for that below if you
want to see more amazing biological
breakthroughs definitely check out my
other videos on this topic so what do
you guys think should humans mess with
nature like this or is this a recipe for
disaster
in your mind do the benefits outweigh
the risks let me know in the comments
section below if you did enjoy this
video please consider subscribing and if
you are a subscriber but haven't checked
out my book new thinking yet it's been
rated the ninth best technology history
book of all time so it's definitely
worth a read to put our current world
into perspective anyway this has been to
gogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the
cheers guys
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]